8 septembre 2010 devant l'ambassade du
chili dans le 7ème à paris une centaine
de chiliens s'est donné rendez vous pour
soutenir les prisonniers mapuche en
grève de la faim depuis deux mois
[Applaudissements]
nestor et président de l'association
terre et liberté pour arauco un
territoire au sud du pays d'où est
originaire le peuple mapuche la plus
importante minorité indienne du chili
nestor et exilés politiques
il se bat depuis près de 15 ans pour
faire connaître les injustices dont
cette communauté est victime une cause
longtemps passé sous silence sont les
jours et puis après une semaine ils
n'ont pas fait des informations
précieuses qu'elles sont importantes sur
les lignes 1 et son père pendant les
séries
mais la vie est un des quatre meilleurs
temps
pourtant
les 34 indiens mapuche en grève de la
faim protestent contre une loi hérité de
la dictature de pinochet les désignant
comme des terroristes un cri de
désespoir sur une situation contraire
aux conventions internationales des
droits de l'homme
[Musique]
les chiliens venus manifester
aujourd'hui ne sont pas tous mapuche
mais pour la plupart comme rossé la
solidarité est indispensable
les sous du santiago du chili mais je
connais la culture m'a poussé mon peuple
tous les chiliens on a des femmes
accouchent ils veulent pas le
reconnaître il va arriver les tous et
européens ils venaient tous étaient plus
tôt blanc les yeux bleus
70 % de la population du chili et
métissée et pourtant au pays les indiens
ne trouvent pas leur place après quatre
siècles de lutte contre les
conquistadors espagnols puis trente ans
de guerre contre les divers
gouvernements le territoire mapuche est
passé de 10 millions d'hectares à 500
milles soit moins d'un pour cent du pays
une zone désormais envahis par les
multinationales de l'industrie
forestière provoquant la désertification
des terres
sur les 8000 chilien recensés en france
une dizaine seulement sont des indiens
mapuche dont red et niasse qui a fui le
chili après des années de lutte de la
terreur avec tornade financière j'étais
impressionne pour le chef on la pierre
le cher pour l'acteur italien si pour le
marché ne récupère territoriaux le wapo
des couvertures et robert revient sur
ses épaules et ma part amis qui paraît
pour le moins poussif et talent est là
trente cinq ans après la fin du régime
dictatorial de pinochet et après
plusieurs gouvernements successifs le
peuple minoritaire mapuche est toujours
la cible de l'étape la manifestation se
termine nestor rentrer chez lui
satisfait de voir que le mouvement pro
mapuche prend enfin de l'ampleur
le lendemain nestor retrouve son ami
roule yann un ancien révolutionnaire
aujourd'hui auteur et spécialiste des
luttes sociales au chili dans les années
ces deux hommes ont vécu aux côtés des
indiens mapuche l'un des nombreux
peuples natifs qui font la richesse de
l'amérique latine à madrid il a 26 pts
différentes au mexique une à 92 le
peuple différent avec son propre langue
avec leurs propres ambitions de muda le
peuple espoir mais
avec la concession de l'état l'état qui
me fait un paquet avec tout ça et
maintenant on est mexicain en un rien de
temps en effet il ya du coup au chili on
assiste à la répression d'une armée
d'êta face à des paysans et si on voit
bien la modernité de tous les appareils
militaires
si dame
nature
tranquille
décline tranquille c'est une lutte et
lutte défensive il a sept ou huit morts
assassinés ma bouche et de la part de
carabine hier et je pense qu'il n'y a
pas un seul cas la vigne et les jours
que s'ils acceptent la provocation est
évidemment qui sera justifiée et des
massacres je pense que la direction
actuelle du peuple mapuche et il est
très intelligente parce qu'effectivement
et tombe dans les pièges black et
mapou site mmorpg
j'ai un client de sanyo de s'y tiennent
[Musique]
le combat de nestor n'est pas terminée
infatigable il repart au pays dans
quelques jours
[Musique]
18 septembre 2010 aujourd'hui c'est le
bicentenaire de l'indépendance du chili
une occasion unique pour les chiliens
d'île de france de se retrouver à
savigny-le-temple
blocus naval couach qui me lie à noter
louera pour faire honneur à son maillot
jaune au salon du bio il est vilain bien
même il
est moins important
chose qu'elle attend
et puis de retrouver un peu l'esprit
chinian
en fait c'est quelque chose qu'on on
perd un peu au quotidien parce qu'on
essaie de s'intégrer
et même au coeur de la fête on n'oublie
pas les indiens mapuche nous dénonçons
ici
la situation critique dans laquelle se
trouve le temps quatre prisonniers
politiques mapuches en grève de la faim
de points depuis plus de 70 jours et
qu'ils sont déterminés à aller jusqu'au
bout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
procès le photographe aperçu devant
l'ambassade à la manifestation de la
semaine précédente est pris par
l'émotion vraiment très dur et très loin
d'où p
honey bah déjà ils sont exilés
politiques économiques tout ce que tu
veux mais ils sont avant tout les
chiliens qui aiment loupé iq et la
plupart de ceux qui te vois ici il
souffre aux l'injustice qu'il ya au
chili parce que ça fait 5 e siècle qui
on combat un public et ses peuples et
les digues qui montre la force et le
courage aussi watrin comme vous sa
fierté pour sa dignité ou sa terre sa
couture a dit
alors que le chili a fêté cette année
ses 200 ans d'indépendance le pays a
toujours du mal à assumer ses origines à
ce jour plus d'une centaine d'indiens
mapuche sont encore détenus dans des
geôles chili
[Musique]